I always wanted to become a beast in
blood-borne but it wasn't possible even
if I fill the beast meter to 100%
however with the old hunters expansion
turning into a beast is finally possible
here's a quick guide on how I got the
beast embrace rune which allows you to
turn into a beast
first and foremost make your way to the
hunters nightmare once you've arrived in
the hunters nightmare proceed until you
can enter the cathedral where you fought
vicar Amelia you'll notice there's a
cleric beast as glowing in flames laying
on an altar pick up the eye pendant from
him which will be used later to get into
the research halls make your way to the
first boss Ludwig and defeat them after
defeating Ludwig proceed past him until
you reach some stairs I will lead to two
members of the healing Church defeat
them both and insert the eye pendant
into the dead body on the altar the
altar will then lift up towards the next
area after you make the top head back to
the hunter's dream once back at the
hunter's dream teleport to the
underground corpse pot once you arrive
there make your way back to where you
inserted the eye pendant you'll notice
that there's a new altar in place of the
altar you took up to the next area here
you'll pick up Lawrence's skull you find
out Lawrence was the first vicar of the
healing Church and that he became the
first cleric beast now make your way
back towards the Cathedral where the
Burning cleric beast was hanging out
defeat Lawrence the first vicar and
you'll receive the Beast embrace rune
head back to the hunter's dream and
equip the beasts embrace rune you'll
notice you've now turned into a beast if
you have them equip your beast claws and
become a killing machine while in beast
mode you'll be able to gain more damage
but you'll also take way more damage so
be careful the Beast claws also have
some new attacks now that you're in
beast form when the Beast claws are
tricked and gained a roar from your l2
you can do a flying attack that can
stagger your opponent for back stabs and
you can use your light and heavy attacks
complex of note you can also use normal
weapons in beastmode but you will not
charge your peace meters good luck with
your beastly adventures and stay tuned
advanced calm for continuing coverage of
blood-borne the old hunters
Oh